their fear is that this could become
illegal
kill the bill protesters in Bristol and
across the UK march today as the
controversial police and crime Bill
continues its journey through Parliament
the idea that my children in the future
might not be able to gather peacefully
and oppose the government
for our kids as well you know this this
Bill gets passed then there could be
something even more serious in the
future that these guys on our bows and
they won't be able to so that yeah we
feel like we need to peacefully fight
for that lots of very vague information
in there that it's not very clear you
know noisy protest I'm in the Summer
band
um we could get one year in prison for
drumming uh it's just draconian it is
abundantly clear that the police do not
need any more power addressing the
crowds one of the Colston four
defendants rhianne Graham she told Sky
News many are fearful of what the bill
could mean well it's a direct attack on
our human rights we have the right to
assemble and to speak up about things
that um we care about and things that
are wrong with our society like we
wouldn't have had the amount of
progressing within our democracy if it
hadn't been for people standing up and
saying otherwise the marches come at a
critical Junction on Monday the House of
Lords votes on this bill and these
protesters see this is one of the last
chances to fight against it the police
crime sentencing and courts bill is
wide-ranging police would be able to put
more conditions on protests including
setting noise and time limits failure to
comply could result in a fine up to 2
500 pounds protest sisters who glue
themselves to buildings or block roads
could be put in prison for up to 51
weeks trespassing would become a crime
but traveling communities worry they
could find their homes seized police
would also be allowed to stop and search
a person without suspicion concerns have
been raised that this could
disproportionately affect black people
who are nine times more likely to be
searched than white people
and the maximum time in prison for
criminal damage to statues would be
extended from three months to ten years
it is these tougher restrictions leading
to hundreds taking to the streets
but those on the front line of policing
say the bill is needed anybody who has
peacefully made their point who has held
placards who stood outside Parliament to
perhaps use PA systems you know
loudspeakers that is not a problem this
is not about stifling democracy or
taking away somebody's Liberty or their
right to express their opinion this is
about making sure that those that do do
that don't put other people's lives in
danger the government says changing
tactics by protesters means a change in
the law is needed but there is anger
that this change goes too far
now why is it Sky News in Bristol